[Musique]
vainqueur premier patient il ya cinq
minutes
[Musique]
trésor là le mec qui te plains tu
regardes qu'ils n'ont souvent pas les
bras par ce contrat devra encore tu vois
yoga prénatal
ah oui au fait que je suis censé y aller
le dalaï lama peut aller se rhabiller
des meilleurs potes avec mon frère
antonio rappaz troisième fois la vie des
autres est tellement mieux
moi ça va vraiment pas alors on va
tester sur instagram là d'accord super
très bon mauvais c'est l'idéal quand tu
déprimes va directement sur le corps de
gisele bündchen 2018 n'a pas besoin d'un
mec pour reprendre sa vie en main mais
pas d'un mec les temps plusieurs pénis
dans son vagin régulièrement va se jouer
elle va elle va à zaz dîner vendredi
soir que je vais t'expliquer tu vas y
aller ma fille je suis bidon je vois
tout sauf quelqu'un de vie d'au moins tu
es magnifique
le mec m'envoie un message lui le moment
je renonce à la vie
son culte je comprends pas il est là
pour la sauver pour la bd battant et
mexes un put plus tôt alors bon c'est un
put plus juste plus voir plus plus plus
plus plus mais comment tu as pu le faire
ce à quoi la cub un peu
[Musique]
et vous êtes trop chelou ce soir vous ne
cachez un truc ou quoi
[Musique]